guardiamo
questa palla
è ferma non si muove perché è in
equilibrio
se uno dà una piccola forza la palla la
palla oscilla ma poi ritorna nel suo
equilibrio iniziale
se ora giriamo l'insalatiera e mettiamo
la palla sopra l'insalatiera la palla
ancora ferma in equilibrio ma appena da
un altra forza la palla cade e devo
essere io a rimetterla sul insalatiera
per mantenere di nuovo l'equilibrio
con questo semplice esempio abbiamo
quindi scoperto un principio della
fisica e dalla natura molto semplice
stare in equilibrio non significa
necessariamente avere stabilita la palla
per esempio un equilibrio stabile quando
sul foglio dell'istat sul fondo
dell'insalatiera ed è in equilibrio
instabile quando è sul dorso
dell'installatore
l'equilibrio è un tema di discussione da
secoli e se ne sono occupati
diverse personaggi di scienziati e di
scrittori di poeti e di cantanti
economisti
einstein diceva che la vita è come
andare in bicicletta per mantenere
l'equilibrio deve continuamente pedalare
di mantenere movimento
secondo dalai lama invece per stare in
equilibrio nella vita non sempre occorre
fare qualcosa a volte bisogna spegnere
tutto rilassarsi e non fare nulla
noi non abbiamo tempo di occuparsi di
queste cose però viviamo la nostra
quotidianità affidandoci a un modello di
vita che onestamente anche abbastanza
stabile facciamo dei debiti per comprare
una casa
cerchiamo un lavoro fisso per avere tre
settimane di ferie d'agosto abbiamo il
cane il giardino e gli amici di sempre
l'abbonamento in palestra perché
costruiamo la nostra vita attorno dagli
elementi che non cambiano così ci sembra
di controllare meglio il nostro
equilibrio
ma è davvero così
avevo 25 anni quando stavo mettendo le
basi per il mio equilibrio stabile
vi fu fatta parola proposta
lasciare il mio lavoro da ingegnere
aeronautico per andare negli stati uniti
a raggiungere un gruppo di matti
è così che si chiamavano loro per
cercare di vincere il più antico trofeo
sportivo del mondo
la coppa america l'america's cup
era il 1990 i matti erano quelli del
moro di venezia la mia conoscenza della
lingua inglese era veramente basic e non
avevo assolutamente idea di come
funzionasse una barca a vela però ci
vuole provare mi presentai colloqui in
giacca e cravatta il mio futuro capo
indossava un paio di pantaloncini gialli
una maglietta rossa macchiata di grasso
non c'è voluto molto a capire che ho
sbagliato qualcosa parole mi prese per
matto mia ruolo all'istante
fu un'avventura fantastica e me la sono
goduta fino in fondo perché ero convinto
che sarebbe stato un capitolo unico
della mia vita e che sarei stato
destinato a tornare a sedermi a una
scrivania
bello fare gli errori in gioventù calo
fu solamente il primo di sette capitoli
quattro dei quali vissuti con gli amici
di luna rossa l'ultimo quello che si è
concluso qualche mese fa in nuova
zelanda
ma non dovete pensare però che lavorare
per un team di coppa america sia
solamente una fantastica avventura
durante tre anni che portano alla
preparazione delle regate si vive una
vita quasi surreale che non ha niente a
che vedere con gli equilibri di una vita
normale per cominciare ci si sposta
spesso ci si sposta molto
si va ovunque il tinte lo richiede e non
per qualche settimana per mesi a volte
anche per anni mio figlio quando
compiuto sei anni aveva vissuto in dieci
case diverse frequentato tra asili e due
scuole differenti
io pensavo che chiamato il telefono
azzurro ed esegue ciò dei genitori un po
instabili wired e poi si lavora tanto
non si passa tanto tempo con il team a
volte si finisce chiesa notte spesso
viaggia notte e se sotto una pressione
costante no
il tempo libero i giorni a disposizione
sono molto pochi io di solito li uso per
farmi la barba
e se sotto una pressione costante perché
c'è sempre questa possibilità che puoi
fare un errore ma l'errore può causare
danni a tutto il team però comunque
rimane sempre un buon umore da che devi
tenere una bella gioè lavori sul mare
alla fine dove ti alleni dove incontri
tifosi dove raccoglie i dati che poi
vengono analizzati per migliorare le
prestazioni insieme ai migliori velisti
e professionisti di tutto il mondo
poi finalmente cominciano le regate
sale la spinta dei tifosi ma sale anche
la tensione si alternano momenti di
gioia e momenti
finché un
team vince l'ultima regata e si porta a
casa la coppa
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e a questo punto che all'improvviso
termina tutto si chiude la base si fanno
gli scatoloni e si va a casa chi ce l'ha
se viene allora assaliti da sentimenti
contrastanti di sollievo e di angoscia
di serenità e di vuoto che dura nord per
settimane a volte anche per mesi
all'improvviso né a mancare la ragione
stessa per cui si è vissuti negli ultimi
anni e se ha un sacco di tempo libero
che non è capire abituato usarlo è come
se in un istante si scendesse della
bicicletta di einstein lanciato a tutta
velocità per cercare la pace e la
serenità del dalai lama
ma non è così semplice
così nel 2015
avevo deciso che era ora di smettere
aveva 50 anni un figlio di tre e darà
tempo di dare un po di stabilità alla
famiglia
ancora una chiamata questa volta dalla
nuova zelanda
era mister dalton il big boss di pinzi
neanche cosa mi implorava di andare a
lavorare per loro
ero molto combattuto perché
era l'istinto mi diceva di
teletrasportarsi all'istante era era il
sogno della mia vita lavorare per loro
ma la ragione dice male tu queste
settimane di pianificazione stavi
finalmente mettendo insieme gli elementi
per stabilizzarsi un po anche comprato
casa e poi no come si fa a rinunciare a
tutto questo però alla fine
non so vi chiedo se qualcuno vuole
alzare la mano qualcuno di voi ha mai
detto una volta almeno nella sua vita
alcuna 1 ancora una è e poi smetto
meno male grazie e chi l'ha fatto più di
una volta
[Applauso]
per cui l'ho fatto ho preso la famiglia
e siamo partiti
durante il viaggio però hanno assalito
un po d'apprensione è cominciato ad
avere dubbio ma dico sarà all altezza di
questi per poi tutto esiste questa
insistenza cercarne la nava scambiato
per qualcun altro forse
mi sentivo come 25 anni prima quando
mero lanciato nell'incognito ma non ero
più un ragazzino alla fine per cui
cercato di distrarmi e ho chiamato lost
e le ho chiesto ma l'aereo su che
viaggiamo instabile o instabile
guardate un po sconcertata ha detto c'è
un in panico non signore non si
preoccupi lari non cade
l'icona lo volevo solamente ad essere un
po così ma erano la mia è una curiosità
va che
questo è un aereo è un aereo stabile
quando viene colpito dalla perturbazione
l'aereo senza che il pilota debba fare
niente
si rimette nel soggetto originale
ritorno all'equilibrio un po come la
palla nel fondo dell'insalatiera
questo invece è un aereo instabile
quando viene colpito da una
perturbazione
e non è molto rassicurante no
il pilota dovrebbe continuamente
manovrare sulle qui liberatore di coda
per cercare di mantenere l'assetto ma
così non avrebbe tempo di fare
nient'altro
com'eri dover sempre a rimettere la
palla sopra il dorso dell'insalatiera
qui abbiamo i due aerei a confronto
chiamo se capiamo le differenze la
freccia verde e la forza peso applicata
nel baricentro dell'aereo
la forza azzurra
e la forza importanza che quella che
permetta lario di volare è la stessa
forza che noi e sperimentiamo quando
mettiamo il braccio fuori dal finestrino
dell'auto e la lasciamo galleggiare così
come se non avesse peso
osservando le due immagini vediamo che
nell'aereo stabile la freccia verde cioè
il baricentro e davanti alla portanza
nell'aereo instabile la freccia verde e
dietro quindi la stabilità è data dalla
posizione del baricentro rispetto alla
portanza man più il baricentro avanti
più l'aereo stabile man mano che e
arretra perde di stabilità fino a che
diventa instabile
ma allora perché i progettisti
vorrebbero farci volare su degli aerei
che sono instabili ma abbastanza
semplice l'arca l'aereo instabile e più
efficiente dal punto di vista
aerodinamico
quindi questo vuol dire che raggiunge
velocità più elevate
distanze maggiori ea da un'autonomia
superiore
e poi oggi ci sono i computer piloti
automatici che permettono la regolazione
automatica quindi è anche abbastanza
probabile che gli aerei su cui noi
viaggiamo oggi abbiano dei margini di
stabilità molto bassi se non addirittura
leggermente instabili così come
all'aereo su karami nuova zelanda alla
fine mi sono fermato era un po instabile
però come ha promesso dalla hostess non
è caduto
arrivato quindi sano e salvo in nuova
zelanda mi sono subito lanciato alla
barca per cercare di
permetterle di navigare anzi di volare
sapete adesso le barche volano giusto si
volano
non proprio così però diciamo da qua
dovranno sull'acqua però da questa
immagine vediamo bene che queste ali
hanno delle piccole ali che si chiamano
files e un timone a forma di t
rovesciata
attraverso il quale si possono sollevare
dall'acqua e sfrecciare fino a 100
chilometri all'ora
l'unica differenza che hanno rispetto
agli aerei e che non hanno un motore
chiaramente sono spinte dal vento e il
vento non è controllabile con un motore
quindi già questo non rende le cose
molto più semplici e poi il vento spinge
da lassù la freccia arancione in alto
dove ci sono le vele e questa spinta
tende a fare ruotare la barca in avanti
come farla cappottare in avanti e quindi
dobbiamo qualche maniera rimettere in
equilibrio questa barca e questo lo
possiamo fare usando le forze che
conosciamo della forza di importanza
freccia blu e la forza peso verde
per dargli la rotazione opposta però
vediamo che il baricentro deve essere
dietro quindi la barca di coppa america
vola
ma il volo è instabile e dice vabbè
tanto ci sono i computer net di un bel
pilota automatico e risolto tutto in
coppa america è proibito non si possono
usare i piloti automatici
e l'equipaggio che con tanta abilità e
coordinazione deve continuamente
regolari fois il timone e le vele
permetterà la barca di stare in
equilibrio mezzo metro dall'acqua e se
l'equipaggio non può permettersi il
minimo errore anche tutti i sistemi di
bordo elettronici meccanici e idraulici
devono essere progettati realizzati e
mantenuti per offrire sempre la massima
delle prestazioni e non potersi
permettere minimo errore perché
altrimenti la barca si appoggia
nell'acqua e rimane lì
inermi oppure può succedere anche di
peggio
da questi problemi però
nascono delle indicazioni importanti
perché si possono migliorare i sistemi
da questi errori si migliorano le
manovre ma soprattutto si riesce anche a
dare la risposta più importante di tutta
la progettazione
fino a quanto possiamo spingere
l'instabilità della barca quindi farla
più rapida pur mantenendo nel controllo
intimi gilan avevano le idee chiarissime
noi facciamo la barca velocissima poi a
controllarla ci penseremo dopo
e io che non volevo sentirmi da meno
detto posso aiutare perché non mettiamo
l'elettronica che avevamo in luna rossa
che è una figata alla fatta io
[Applauso]
[Musica]
i
kiwi e sono molto diffidenti ma sono
anche curiosi ha detto va bene vai
avanti vediamo un po
l'inizio è stato un disastro
l'elettronica stand naturalmente si
inceppava facciamo i controlli tutto
regolare
andavamo a navigare dopo un po si
inceppava e così per qualche giorno
finché
il grande capo sempre lui convoca una
riunione appena seduto ma guardato negli
occhi e puntandomi l'indice contro ha
detto non so come non so con l'aiuto di
chi e non so quanto ti ci vorrà ma
questa barca domani deve navigare e
senza problemi
se sisde kiwi way
grazie
riunione finita io l'ho detto io credo
che ormai anche l'elettronica abbia
un'anima che come me subisce l'influsso
dell'emisfero capovolto la diffidenza
dei kiwi ma coordinato che quella notte
ho ribaltato tutto ho fatto modifiche
che erano dettate dalla disperazione più
dare qualche intuito tecnologico però il
giorno dopo funzionato il giorno dopo
funzionato e quello dopo ancora finché
finalmente erano tutti contenti
neanche il capo era contento le note si
è avvicinato e ha detto ma è bravo ma ma
come hai fatto
this is the italian way
[Musica]
[Applauso]
alla fine quella coppa l'abbiamo vinta
erano state adottate delle soluzioni
tecnologiche molto all'avanguardia ma
anche molto rischiose ma alla fine
l'hanno pagato durante la conferenza
stampa finale il grande capo era detto
che l'impostazione progettuale era stata
quella di lanciare la palla il più
lontano possibile
e fare tutto il necessario per andarla a
raggiungere
in tutti questi anni ho capito che
alcune leggi della fisica si applicano
anche alla vita
sono stati realizzati aerei e più
efficienti sono state fatte volare
barche semplicemente spostando il
baricentro e imparando a controllare
l'equilibrio instabile
ma anche noi possiamo spostare il nostro
di equilibrio ma fino a quando
se siamo disposti a rinunciare un po
della nostra stabilità saremo pronti ad
accettare le cadute
come un'occasione per crescere
allora ci si può prospettare una vita
intensa e piena di soddisfazioni
quindi ho capito anche questo lancia la
palla il più lontano possibile e fa
tutto il necessario per andarla a
raggiungere
[Applauso]
[Musica]
grazie a un ultima cosa se volete c'è
una palla da raggiungere
[Musica]
[Applauso]